[Music]
kelly is in traverse city michigan hi
kelly welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave and rachel it's a pleasure
talking to you both you too how can we
help
my husband and i are disagreeing on what
to do with his student loans
we currently owe 17 000
we have the cash right now to pay them
off
but we're both registered nurses here in
northern michigan and the ceo of our
hospital
is implementing a retention plan which
is
forgiveness for 12 000 of federal
student loans
but because it's a retention plan it is
200 a month for the next you know four
to five years
and i would like to just pay them off
and be done with it and not have the
debt hanging over ahead but my husband
um
thinks that taking advantage of this
free money is the smarter
it's not supportive
so what do you do in your marriage when
your husband's wrong
well
kelly i'm sorry i feel for you i do
and this is hard because here's
oh let's come back let's come back to
this this is a good conversation okay
all right all right hold on hold on
kelly we'll come back rachel rachel
wants to be reasonable hold on we'll
come right back we're talking with kelly
in traverse city michigan her
hospital is offering a twelve thousand
dollar forgiveness over five years
um and uh they owe seventeen thousand
student loans they have the money to pay
it off she wants to pay it off her
husband doesn't what do i do was her
question and i was joking with her and
saying what do you do when your
husband's wrong but um so anyway that's
how far we got is that a fair summary of
what you told us kelly
yeah okay
okay so what i was going to say kelly is
and again this is a little stereotypical
so it's not true 100 of the time but
generally men
tend to lean more on
kind of that the the logic
math side a little less on the emotional
side right women can i feel like can
naturally go there a little bit quicker
than men so when it comes to debt and
and even student loans there's this
this idea that yeah if i can just do the
math it's going to play out right so
he's looking at the math he's seeing the
logic and he's thinking yeah i mean
someone's going to pay this off this is
great
where you're feeling on the other end we
have the money and there's a level of of
probably less stress a level of freedom
that you know you're going to experience
when this is paid off am i am i right or
wrong is this correct right yeah yes
so whenever couples do tend to disagree
especially when it comes to money um i
think
going to him because you hesitated when
he said what are you doing your
husband's wrong uh so i don't know how
you guys do conflict i don't know how
you come to decision making uh we've
only been talking for about 30 seconds
but
one thing i really would encourage you
to do is to go to him and we always say
tell him your why
and and and that why
may not make logical sense because to
him he's thinking i'm going to get free
money
and someone's going to pay this off and
you know
x y and z
and to really unpack with him
you what you're seeing what you're
feeling
and why you want this paid off and that
could be because you don't want
your
destiny in someone else's hands we talk
about that a lot when it comes to
student loans a lot of people depend on
whether it's
dc or these programs that say hey if you
work for us 10 years we'll pay it off
who knows what's going to happen right
in all this time
and when you're passive and you let
other people
handle your future you're letting go of
really the will to go and say i can
change my life so there could be an
ownership issue that you struggle with
for you maybe you are just stressed with
just having debt whether it was a car
loan or student loan doesn't matter
you don't like having the debt i don't
know what it is for you kelly but
whatever that why is of i
i want this paid off because we have the
money
go to him with that first and foremost
versus blaming or
being accusatory uh really when you go
with that why i think it's one of the
best ways to start and open up the
conversation
so that is really good counsel let me
give you the let me tell you why he's
wrong and maybe that'll help too
okay okay if you told me they were going
to pay you 12 000 as a retention bonus
in 12 months
i'd go with him on it
but you're not you're getting two
hundred dollars a month it's not
speeding
it's not spit that's twenty four hundred
dollars a year
right and that's just dragging out
forever
forever and this is this is golden
handcuffs in a highly volatile
coveted laced vaccination world
that you live in the middle of
where where health care workers are
on the front line and you don't want to
be handcuffed to anything you want to
keep your freedom because you may have
to make some different choices
and this is golden handcuffs
yeah right now the the interest is zero
percent so interest isn't relevant to
that side of it right but when once it
goes back that's 90 200 isn't even
covering the interest
that's a good point too
mathematically but here's the thing it's
dragging out too long it the free money
is not worth the trade-off
for the length of time if it was a short
period of time
i would i would i would throw the flag
and i would argue with you that he was
right okay
uh but it's too long it's drug out the
borrower is slave to the lender and and
rachel's right there's a sense that of
release there's a sense of
employment freedom
of medical freedom
your medical freedoms aren't
trapped you've got you get to choose
what happens in these if you don't
handcuff yourself to one particular
situation and the trade-off is not worth
it here because it's just too long and
uh you know the the
and all of this to say
five years from today ten years from
today which of these two decisions puts
you guys in the best position
paying off today paying off today yeah
and the reason it puts you in the best
position is it frees you up to work
wherever you freaking choose to work
that is best for you
and you don't you're not looking over
your shoulder going oh but they got that
student loan forgiveness thing you know
and you're not you're not handcuffed to
it uh and so it's golden handcuffs is
what it is and and that's why they're
doing it by the way
it's retention and it's why they're
dragging it out
it's to keep you in a volatile
environment for healthcare workers
uh you guys are you know that that world
is has been going through medical hell
now it's starting to go through legal
and vaccination hell and there's just a
huge turnover huge problem there's going
to be a huge shortage of health care
workers
uh with what's going on out there and
it's the same thing with teachers same
thing with policemen
and uh when the teachers the healthcare
workers and the policemen in our culture
are all being mistreated at the same
time
we as a culture
we've got some issues coming that aren't
going to be pretty yeah and you're going
to be caught right in the middle of that
you're going to be caught right in the
middle of that trapped by this one
decision to get a little bit of free
money it ain't worth it kiddo it is
worth it and again this is when we
always say here on the show personal
finance it's 80 behavior it's 20 head
knowledge the head knowledge part the
logic part that he's functioning in
there's so much more when it comes to
money than just looking at just the math
and so but but when you sit in the math
that's what he's playing over and over
and over but
his math formula is wrong my point okay
because here's the situation here's
what's coming in her world she's gonna
have the opportunity to
raise her income by more than twelve
thousand dollars by changing jobs
62 times in the next five years yep and
she doesn't want to be trapped with a
stupid little 12 thousand dollar benefit
over here in that particular job 100 no
i hear that totally but again he has to
be able to get above that and look at
all the options on the table yeah yes
partly mounted he went down he went down
the rabbit hole got stuck down there
with a little short term
a little limited vision on the math
that's my point yeah and he's super
nerding
and didn't miss some of the variables